what's up our next guest is a former
cast member of saturday night live who
went on to star in some great shows like
black monday and marry me she's also
written a book it's called the wreckage
of my presence
the best title ever and it's out right
now please welcome casey wilson
[Music]
oh my gosh you have my favorite color of
hair
it's my favorite color of brown you can
have it i can it doesn't work as well on
me
a blonde doesn't suit me on my
personality i carry it i'm a chameleon
i'll
i'll just you know dive into whatever
color but i love your color it's so
beautiful
yeah you look beautiful thank you so
much i decided to bring some color
perhaps too much but
no i think you look gorgeous i was like
god you walked in and i felt happier all
of a sudden
so well done yeah so happy to meet you i
love you oh well it's nice to meet you
too i have to ask you i'm from a reality
show and i hear that you really love
reality
i do okay i know funny i'm from reality
show
i don't really watch it oh i wish i
could get on one no
i i am i'm in love i love the real
housewives and people may say what they
will i'm no longer a housewives
apologist i've come out of the closet
about that
and i feel comfortable with that truth
with my truth
um yeah i was lucky enough to see the
very first airing of the very first
episode of orange county about 15 years
ago and i'd like that in my obituary
i gotta be honest with you like most of
my friends love those shows so like yeah
i'm the oddball
of the girl you're a person of dignity
no it's really not that it's
or yeah we'll filter it that way but
it's really i just don't have a lot of
time
that's my thing i guess i feel i have to
and i'm a mom too i don't know where i'm
finding the time but i am finding oh my
god okay write that book yeah how to
find time
um well congrats on the book it's
writing a book is a big deal it's a lot
that goes into it i always feel like
people always ask me
i'm like that's too much pressure i'm
i'm not and i don't know if i want to be
that open
um so where and i'm a very open person
so where did the title come from though
because the wreckage of my presence is
an
amazing title and i paint such a good
picture it paints quite a picture uh
it's kind of about my 20s and 30s and
the wreckage i left in my wake
but i got the title i was just at a
random meeting like you are you know
like a bunch of parents everyone's
sitting around and everybody had left
like snapple bottles and diet coke and
when we left the head of the meeting
just casually said to everyone's like
don't forget to bring with you the
wreckage of your presence
and everyone was like oh that's a heavy
phrase for
you know your starbucks cup but it felt
i was like i
love that phrase it's great yes and it
really does depict like how you're
feeling in certain moments or what is
your life and certain points everything
i've left behind
you're like well some aren't all
positive from footprints
but you you write about you and your
husband being bed people so first of all
congratulations
on that relationship and what exactly
does that entail
great question kelly uh so a bed person
to me you know my husband and i we have
two small children we're just so tired
all the time that
i tend to try to do everything i can
from bed and this was pretty pandemic
i'm in that bed i'm taking meals i'm
taking friends and letting them snuggle
right up next to me i'll do anything
from there or the bath
or the bath yes you can have your
girlfriends if you need a ketchup just
perch
right on a little chair right there with
you as a 40 year old woman
yeah and i'm not getting bubbles to like
cover up it's like you see what you see
it's your fault that's on you yes on you
[Laughter]
and you're welcome yes pick a long look
this is goals um so is it true that your
dad is here publicist for this
my father god bless him paul wilson
would like to be my publicist and he has
made
several promotional videos for my book
and
amazing he's very sweet throughout the
process he's very worried about like was
i going to
put enough in there that would sell
there he is oh my god i love your dad
this picture says
so much that's him every morning in his
hot tub the neighbors had to build up
that foliage where does he live
narnia like he lives in alexandria
virginia
wow but all the neighbors have built
hedges and foliage because he's out
there every morning
with his cigar in the hot tub talking
loudly on on his phone
so they're like we don't need to see
paul wilson every morning in the half
nude
but he's a bad person too see we like to
be submerged
apple tree i like it yes um your dad
looks fun as hell
he is fun he's a great dad but he's
always like i know this is going to
disturb everyone but he just wants the
book to sell so he's like did you put
sex in there i'm like
he's like sex
oh my god were you were you pretty open
in it though like
about i was yes absolutely very
comedically uh
about obviously funny things like things
i've said but also my mom passed about
15 years ago so there's a lot
in the book about grief and motherhood
and what that brings up um
yeah you know parenting when you've lost
a parent and yeah
so i hope i touch on a little of
everything not just comedy but
yeah and there's all different forms of
that with grief like
they don't have to die they could just
not be present 100 percent
yes yeah no it's important that you're
open about that that's cool people can
i had a therapist once when a boyfriend
broke up with me and she was like he's
passed but he's still
going around living and it's very that i
don't have that experience
just kidding i'm totally kidding walk
off of a cliff
i heard when people remain alive that
you want dad
this is the next book we're writing it
right now yeah
all right well everybody casey's book is
called the wreckage of my presence
you've got to check it out
want more fun stuff i thought so check
out these videos floating around my head
this one is really cool i'm just saying
no pressure